yes we did cuz we back at it again it's
the fighter in the kid this is really
the fighter in the kid come on baby I I
want to apologize if it seems like
there's a metamorphosis taking place and
I look a little more robust and you see
why when you said that here we go you
mind because the chin and sonaz kind of
went what's going on with you why do you
look why do you look that muscular that
tent I said you look bigger
do a lot of it is that you guys know
no please be quiet the problem is I do
train crazy hard as you guys all know no
we see do the 10 dips no no no I that
well that's a warm-up dude I just get my
body fired up I fire my my glutes I'm
going to sit down I work out this
morning so I'm going to go work out at
3:30 you haven't worked out I'm going to
work out at 3:30 no you're not yes I am
I work out with my trainer where at uh I
in a parking lot actually if you must
know in a parking
lot I'm abini outside it's good stuff
now now anyway the point is I'm taking
in a lot more protein so I apologize in
advance if I start to look pretty
[__]
scary I do and I know that you're kind
of a big guy and you're 270 or whatever
and you have issues with you know I know
that I'm small compared to you but don't
push me okay and I'm going to tell you
why I have a lot of energy and I'm
feeling aggressive cuz I've never heard
this before don't push me as always I've
never heard before but I've been
watching you ready for this Kung Fu nope
day Jiu-Jitsu tutorials that should help
it does help you know what you're doing
you're not wasting your time at all it's
so productive dude well such a good way
I'm watching my son do jiujitsu I go to
my son's Jiu-Jitsu you want to little
bit little bit you know it's good so
once again once again I'm say this again
don't push me you been watching juu on
YouTube because I've been absorbing not
watching absorbing I've been absorbing
jiujitsu tutorials tutorials got me now
which which ones are you watching I I
have a range of tutorials from a range
of experts just like give me the don't
say Marcelo Garcia at add you know there
is some of that there is no but just
like the tutorial so Hano sometimes will
give a little something something on how
to get out of a [__] triang not afraz
that we know the tutorials there's
another guy named mat mat Royal is that
it mat Royal is that him bring him up
bring up mat Royo I like mat Royo he
teaches there he is that [__] dude is
awesome don't kid yourself with that F
the UFC yeah matter Royal is no joke and
and I he's a real technician and I I'm
his I'm his disciple he doesn't know it
but I'm his disciple oh when you say
you're watching tutorials you're on
Instagram did you just watch the Batista
Batista Bomb and this is why I wanted to
go down this road cuz I knew you you
don't know if I am yeah oh you before
you came in the studio you clicked on
his in
sometimes I follow I'm a discip I'm a
royal disciple yeah okay that's what you
need to know don't push me bro no dude
with this Instagram Jiu-Jitsu you're
learning people should be scared dude
look at him here talk with Batista the
WWE he's no joke either no dude don't
legit hey with Batista and you dude I
don't know if I'm betting on you I don't
either was he a purple belt he's a brown
belt bro oh no he's a brown belt and
he's very big and strong he's very big
and strong every bit every bit 260 every
bit too dude hey he's got a I've seen
the man's frame he's got a [__] frame
he's jacked I've seen person he's jacked
he's he's he's big boy yeah I beat the
show uh I'm sorry what were you saying
yeah wait be respectful no the guy from
guardians the Galaxy don't say that the
the guy dude he fought MMA no no he
fought he did have a couple MMA fight he
did what league well doesn't count okay
come on do you see where we're getting
at today bro you're pushing me and
you're pushing my my sensei who doesn't
know that I'm even a student this a new
Brendon here I don't I cut straight to
the chase here look at that though you
don't look bigger he can't fight I do
chin can't see man you are I do have a
bad Vision you know what is you know
what it is it's no [__] compliment it's
no [__] Wednesday I didn't I didn't I
didn't agree to that yeah dud every
Wednesday is no [__] Wednesday yeah dude
was no [__] I'm no [__] I'm not taking
sh I'm smelling a lot of [__] cuz you're
not watching juu tutorials doesn't think
yes I am and and I watch box tutorials
too and I'll tell you something else I'm
I'm ready so whatever you want and
whatever you got today I'm already
warmed up go roll with Batista dude I'll
roll with anybody I will I'll roll with
anybody he's he has to be 60 he he looks
good I don't think so B I think he's my
age or younger I hate to tell you 54
he's he's two years younger than
me yeah yeah now
I'm a fan that's the problem this is
what happens dude you you po poke the
bear poke the bear I'm a fan of Batista
what he's done yeah his acting chops and
go in the galaxy did I get you going a
little bit gr what I get you going a
little bit no I get you going when I
start talking that's Vin Diesel yeah he
was dra the Destroyer dude how much
money does Vin Diesel get for playing gr
they he just goes grw and you know what
I thought about that I watched that on
the plane I didn't watch it somebody was
watching on the plane and I thought to
myself in that movie you're usually
behind a green screen or you're up on a
a bed like a truck and they put the car
up there so you're doing this sure and
then you're going like
this and it's all that facial stuff and
you have about six lines in the movie I
think and have you seen how much money
he gets paid no no I understand it's
just a throw two big black dicks in for
that yeah yeah a
w it's weird right
it's but
it's can't I can't right now don't do
that again you're trying to say how hard
his life is or like how boring it is how
boring but the money you're literally
like what do you want yeah that's right
uh so anyways what I'm going to do with
my money in your head you're just
thinking I'm going to go buy this this
house in Malibu I had two more weeks of
this [__] well he's a producer on it
so I think he made crazy amount of money
and then he has a fast and furious
too 13 million for each portrayal of
talking
tree um of the talking tree no I think
he he um that's every movie there's been
four of them okay yeah that's so much
money you Gard gy no but uh Fast and
Furious there are 10 well Fast and
Furious he owns that well he owns the
exec producer something like that he
close to being a billionaire from fast
and fur fast fur is different animal
we're talking about stupid group what
would you and I if we wrote a movie what
would it be called and what would be
Bubba those days have passed they have
we've missed that boat we did we did
you're 5 I know 40 so what would you
call it we're not Matt Damon and Ben
aake dude are we just two guys we're not
yeah we're just two guys are we just
some guys we were just guys just couple
one two now when we first met maybe a
little bushy eyed little you know we had
our [__] together a little bit but then
that boat passed we're not the dorms we
don't have any scripts if we start if we
start doing a YouTube series it's just
real short and it's you and I out there
on a tand bike or you know what vibe
you're giving me YouTube Ain't it I'm
too what YouTube Ain't it for it
you know what it is Daddy and this might
are you GNA say for your future only
fans is it only fans yeah I'm looking at
only you're you give only fans Vibes
well what about um and your new body you
put on five pounds right what about
Pornhub Pornhub no you got to cut out
the middleman so what if we do a a TV
show where you're driving your
ridiculous stupid truck and I'm in the
driver's seat and I'm always like dude
you're going too fast you're wasting gas
you know that's not gon to work right
off the bat cuz I mean we've been
through this cuz my car doesn't allow
[__] right so that movie is not going
to be made wait what right cuz you can't
get in the car won't start if you're in
it what it's weird dude no yeah had some
guy jump in from Iran and he had a Comm
hair shirt on went oh no I'm out of here
it wouldn't
start I don't but I'm not a KLA Harris
supporter well but but wait hey hey but
sure I'm not just drive a test for the
show sure dude just cuz I drive a Tesla
3 doesn't mean I'm a [__] even I might
be but I mean but that's only my own K
that's my Kink the point all I'm saying
is the car won't even the truck won't
even start it's weird man it like knows
when there's [__] no dude you're so
disrespectful I don't like it either
dude I'm like I'll try and Hotwire this
thing it won't even work I studied
Jiu-Jitsu via Instagram and I [__] I
do boxing tutorial it's so
offensive it's so offensive dude I st
just see tutorials in my I'm like he saw
something on Instagram 100% by the way
dude are you excited to go to Austin yes
fight companion how much fun are those
[__] great flying in Friday Friday
night you you're going to get there
early you going to go to the Mother Ship
or something what's going on I'm not
getting there that early I just don't
want to uh yeah I mean I might stop by
there I probably 6 a.m. on Saturday bad
idea that means I got to wake up at 4:30
and you know how that goes you're a [__]
you're a zombie I'm not doing it I'm up
I I was leaning towards I'm up at
usually I'm around up around 4:35 at the
latest I'm always up at 5:00 a.m. so I
like could do a 6 a.m. flight it's just
a long day and you're flying back the
same day put your best fo forward I just
the problem with me is it gets in the
way of my protein regimen and my my my
like Batista dude yeah yeah those would
be fun but can I tell you something
that's been bothering me I'll AAR it out
on here yeah you know and I get I get it
Rogan's a big deal dude that show is
massive massive show you you always find
time to do his fight Companions and it's
in another city what do you mean and
then I do fight comp B I know I'm not
Roan but you can never do it hold on
because I didn't have a date I was
supposed to be in Boise I did that that
got canceled and now I so I had the
weekend open open free yeah and it's
just that when I'm doing a show in a
city I can't not do that show and come
and do the fight companion here also
Joe's Joe I know I get it also even if I
was like say I was really mad at Joe for
whatever reason maybe he punched me in
the face or something said get out of
here and I was like [__] that guy and
then he was like you want to do the
fight man I go yes like I'd say before
he got it out I go yes yeah but I'm mad
I get it and then I'd go yeah say less
yeah yeah so cuz I want to do I hate to
say that at 56 CU I'm I'm done doing
campaigns with people that I'm not super
close with like they don't make it as
fun so but you got the Francis and you
got the fury fight coming up that's the
28th I'd like doing for that you got the
big November 11th fight Jon Jones steeve
I'd like do one for that the big
December fight I'm free those those
those weekends I think my next weekend
after 28th you're not I got I got
shamberg this coming this coming weekend
well not this weekend not this we next
weekend 20 27th 28 yeah so 20 then
November 7th no 9th and 10th and 11th is
the next date I have so I'm free yeah
the next one's the 11th is it then the
next big UFC is 11th chin brenon you
want to take a little break could we
please you know what I want to take a
break I need a break I would love to go
to Vegas dude now hear me out here I
don't know if this is something real I'd
love to go to Vegas and go to a a
musical
festival burning man but better burning
man but better and I wish our good buddy
my brother from a very smart mother
Aubrey Marcus ran this oh you know
what's funny you know I like Area 51 but
you know I like better Area 15 cuz Area
51 you get kicked off of but area 55 is
its own kind of thing you know my
favorite band besides Jared Leto 3
thingss to Mars they're not going to be
there not bu if you say chomo Dr fresh
Elder Brook gy Wolf and The Glitch Mob
I'm going to freak out chomo is my fave
well I like Troy Boy too because they're
going to be there Arcadia we're talking
about Arcadia is this we're talking
about Arcadia all right and Arcadia is
going to be November 2 through 5
November 2 through 5 it's coming up area
15 Nevada it is a mind bending
venue Arcadia Festival of a more
beautiful world and that's really how it
is because I'm not going to speak for
Aubrey but I know uh something about
something about um um Burning Man kind
of rubbed him the wrong way it became
corporatized it became sort of like
people started like making too much
money on it and stuff he was like I'm
want to start my own thing so you can be
part of something the beginnings of
something that's going to be legendary
cuz our boy Aubrey doesn't miss step in
a world where anything is possible and
the beauty of the human expression takes
Center Stage as they all come together
to create a more beautiful world that is
his mission to get to selling out prices
are going up so head on over to fitfor
service.com
Arcadia Arcadia yeah fitfor service fit
f r service.com RK a r k a d a um and
it's fit for service.com Arcadia a r k a
d a because that's I love doing the
fight companions in Austin because it's
all all three four of us and I feel like
I miss that like the only time we get to
see yeah you and I don't have that hang
anymore yeah nov you can't even do the
big boy you're working on that can't be
great for ticket
sales November 11th that massive of a
fight that's a big fight it's the most
expensive like UFC you always I think
you was it you were always said that mic
has a very very good chance against John
I never said that okay you don't think
he does uh I won't say that I'm I love
Stipe I love him um it's a tough fight
depend what version we get of Stipe he's
put on weight he's going be bigger
John's got smaller mean he's had a long
time off which I think was very smart to
take off right yeah it's tough to take
that long off and then fight in a
heavyweight Main Event how long's it
been since Stipe fought [__] cuz I hated
the way he was talking after that uh
Cormier was Cormier the last fight he
had
nanu yeah he lost nanu that's right
that's right he's a year older me or two
years older than me I think too is he
really 2021
March okay that's a hot second a and
then you jump back in and you're not
fighting just anybody you're fighting
Jon Jones you're fighting the best ever
he's 41 years old yeah so one year older
than how old is John 30 36 37 dude you
know I'm balls deep in playoff baseball
I love Bryce Harper I'll watch it they
had this pitcher pitching up 40 I
thought
wow 40 is that the guy with the dreads
who was he no that guy looks like he
stinks talking about the guy with dreads
for the Phillies the left fielder no the
the guy for Arizona actually not for the
Phillies oh there guy for the Phil just
look like he smells really he has like
dreads and a long beard well John's 250
so um he he was heavier when he fought
um serial gun and I told me and him were
both at the event with monster I've
never seen such good shape when I saw
went oh Ste is in trouble oh he's in
trouble Jesus what your what are your
thoughts on uh Israel taking retiring
he's not retiring how taking time off
brilliant yeah I love it AG it's exact
should a smart guy to do that he's
fought 11 times in years some time all
all main events like you
people sure but also like when you're
the main event your obligations to the
media are different they're expecting
you to sell the pay-per-views so the
amount of work it'd be like you know if
you're doing a movie and doing it with
Robert daero back in the day not now but
back in the day you're doing a movie
with Robert daero he has a different set
of requirements with the media than the
fourth lead has right so when you're
Izzy you're always the Robert daero of
the movie and they're Bank on you to
sell the pay-per-views it's a lot a lot
of work he's done it 11 times the past
four years it's it no one and he's been
the most active champ he needs a break
dude people forget he laed the
competition you almost have forgot he La
they had to go out and find Alex Pier
who wasn't even MMA really and catapult
him to the front to get new competition
yeah that's how good he is yeah and I
also I was saying this on the shop show
like you're witnessing once in a
generational Talent you you're taking it
for granted so him leaving I think be
like damn I miss Izzy you see these
other middleweights who are good they're
not Izzy good you don't realize how
special Izzy is till he's gone so I
think him leaving people go ah [__] he
was really good so you appreciate him
more when he comes back
yeah yeah any other brain
Busters
um
no wait you guys were mentioning weight
right what about we saw you yeah we saw
a post of this remember this controversy
back in the day J you remember how much
[__] I got for this well you got [__]
from everybody for this includ our dear
friend Joe Rogan told me I need a
Handler yeah you got a lot of [__] that
hurt my feelings and I let him but I
also thought well you know you're also
just kind of coming up with content and
talking but no but no no no I'm not a
gotcha guy that does this like oh it
just didn't make sense to you hamai C
cheating with a dude click here no no no
no I said this because I usually know
what the hell I'm talking about yeah
well so what was it about this like you
the way it went down you you you saw
that people were L as interested in this
fight because kot so much bigger and
blah blah blah the UFC just
miscalculated they had Hamot fighting
Nate Diaz his last fight they thought
you know they're going to discipline
Nate Diaz he's going to ride off the
sunset and fight Jake Paul like nope
we're not allowing that we're going to
feed you to the worst matchup possible
they thought all the fans would support
it like they always do and they went no
no we don't like this man we love Nate
deal this is [__] up what you're doing
the week up they see it trending down
UFC knows how pay-per-view is going to
do before it even hits and they're like
we had to do a switch up here there you
go and hamzat alluded in the press
conference at UFC 294 today on Ma you
have been rather Vindicated here sir I
know people still be like oh it doesn't
mean anything let me see go ahead Jim he
didn't make weight and everyone speak
about my I didn't make weight you know
once in my life and there was some plans
to do that that way it's not my PL but I
can't say everything here and
yeah I mean go I mean do you want to
apologize I didn't say anything didn't
do anything everyone apologize on behalf
of everybody though I want to apologize
behalf of do you want me to do it the
way the mafia does watch this all right
Mr sh but we're on the mafia I want to
apologize on behalf of all the fans out
there than you including Mr Rogan he's
he feels really bad condolences say that
for he sends his he sends not his
condolences cuz nobody dead yet but we'd
appreciate it if you could check your
Fury and not chin check everybody or
lock a door and pull everybody's head
off I like that you understand I forgive
you so thank you we appreciate that very
much and as as a small symbol of our
appreciation we like to give you a
second rain oh I have a ton of these but
thank you but we'd also like to give you
I don't know if you know about magic
mind but it's a beautiful thing it gives
you a you feel alert instead of jittery
it's not that it's uh it's not like
Focus get in the Flow State it gets you
in a flow state so we'd like you a nice
little gift yeah it's a nice little
thing one shot it's all you need
complely six hours of bliss you know
that's how it is completely forgive you
yeah it takes away all the distractions
you get into this FL were not nice yeah
I know I know especially your friend
Joseph we apologize so why don't we down
a a little magic mind guys if you want
some of this um there's nothing like
this all right it's fantastic you can it
allows you to be your best creative self
and I drink it every day and yes I'm
addicted to it but it's not several of
them I know yeah I thought that was
interesting but who knows who knows who
knows I'm excited for those fights I
like this chin did you see uh in the
open workouts Kamar Usman pop his knee
tell gatei goes damn I popped my knee I
saw pop upag [__] they're going to call
the fight off Justin G you Bab ready to
go then Justin was like no's
fine and I had some people you guys
would know in the MMA space like dude
you see him pop his knee I was like
listen he could have three healthy knees
he's not being
Hamot wait hold on it's like I pop my
knee and then they just run
off ow it's hard to hear but it does
sound like I mean he looks like he's
injured um Justin goes you all right he
goes uh something popped but they said
the fight's still on I mean it has to be
so so you don't think uh he has a chance
against very tough fight yeah I
know I love kamaro but yeah tough
one we'll see it's MMA you never know I
didn't think Strickland had a chance
either yeah and gonu too remember his
knee was messed up against
gone yes it's true though very different
fight but still very different fight and
gone is a striker and he took him down
and messed him up there so yeah but
that's cuz s gone can't wrestle with
[__] interesting who would you say if
you would even know you may not know but
who would you think is a higher level
wrestler kamad or Camaro oh boy I
wouldn't know
Hamza why I mean he he that dagistan
wrestling come up the way he did with
the MMA also Kamar doesn't you know more
of a collegate fol style freestyle
freestyle and then he's like bad knees
mhm so bad knees and then even Leon
Edwards I think we got to give credit
Leon Edwards He's got a lot better his
takedown defense but if he can't take
Leon
down you g take hamzad down you know how
big hamzad is I don't big boy yeah
although Camaro is
big small he's not Hamza big he's not
Hamza big no like Hamza could fight that
light heavy at
205 camar could
never now if if you had to guess are
they paying pay a lot of money ton of
money oh that's good I'm glad yeah
because it's in uh Abu Dhabi they have
to put on huge fights they owe it to the
the government basically because they
guarantee him a certain amount of
Superstar fights oh look at him and look
at him and Daniel yeah he picked up
Daniel here okay okay so Daniel's very
thick
that's oh jeez grabbing grabbing two
time Olympian
Daniel and there was a video of um
Camaro next to Islam kamaro looks
smaller than Islam which is kind of yeah
kamaro's not a big
welterweight yeah you would Define Kamar
as a big welterweight no he probably
walks around at 80ish you know I feel
like he walks around at 200 no really no
he's he's short
man especially for welterweight be tough
for
him he's yeah he's definitely small for
an
85 oh yeah he's not a big seven years so
it would be a big and this is at 185
yes this is at 85 yeah yeah
yeah so walks run 190 now do you do you
to push you a little bit on this do you
think it goes all five rounds not a
chance really no I think with Kamar with
his bad knees especially now that the
one popped he's going be forced to stay
with Hamot and and he doesn't use kicks
to control the distance so Hamot hits
like a ma truck it's going to be tough
yeah he gets finished I think but he's
going to get paid he has big balls you
know yep it's also MMA Camaro does have
some knockout power now but at
welterweight we'll see if it translates
to middleweight so who knows what could
happen but also fair is mentioning that
you're talking about kamot I mean you're
talking about Kamar Usman who's
pound-for-pound one of the greatest and
you could make the argument for sure
long long defense of his title for sure
you want to bet on it
um depends on what the bet
is right so I the odds are near the
issue is does he last five rounds oh
I'll bet you that yeah no this thing
this thing's under three this I don't
think it's a good thing to bet on cuz
it's like last late notice fight like
you said and it's like that's why you
would bet on it man that's it's called
prop bets don't be a [__] you want a bet
[__] don't don't bring the because
you're taking because you're taking com
money well no I'll bet you uh com up
hamz up finishes under three rounds i i
i that pop of the knee makes me nervous
oh don't back out now you're talking all
this [__] the goat he's one 90 built
like a stingray come on
no no under three rounds what were the
what are the odds on that chin the prop
bet so under three rounds by the way
comes out I I think kamaro walks around
to 200 and he's about
5'11 so so I don't know about the prop
bets but right now this is the so it be
so it's minus 185 so it's heavily favor
under two and a half is minus 166 okay
so they're on my line of thinking
yeah yeah I don't know those are insane
odds dude for him to get a finish that
means Vegas thinks he's for sure going
to get a finish under two and a half
rounds
yeah yeah I don't I'm not a gambler for
a
reason uh volovski MV that's a that's a
that's a better
one the the over 5 half rounds minus
130 I don't think he finishes Alex no
unless it's a cardio issue no I don't
either I mean uh I'll tell you something
off the record once we get out of here
okay really yep really that would change
your betting well hold on we're let's
take a little break sure yeah I assume
the winner of uh Johnny Walker and uh
mamed get the next shot at the title
yeah cuz Jamal Hill still out then you
have uh Yan and Alex Pier fighting light
heavyweights popping right now dude no
no Yi y Yi yeah y sorry
yeah yeah light heavyweights popping and
I'm not talking about Camaro's knee
either that division is
popping now uh is Yuri when is Yuri
fighting fighting Alex in November
they're on the Jon Jones steep Bay card
wow God that card St the ticket prices
for that M Square G are so insane I bet
for like nose bleeds like 1,800 what
there it is so your main event Jon Jones
St Bay yui Alex Matt our boy Matt fola
they gave him a tough
fight Russ card is cool you know
hopefully Kenzie D and Jessica andr this
weekend's card is better than this for
[Music]
sure okay all right okay okay M oh yeah
oh it's it's going to be one of the C
events but I'm just going to do it now I
was looking last you know mean I love
Halloween I like haunted houses mhm
someone dm'd me was like dude would you
do this saw it it's this haunted hous a
waiver in Tennessee you got to sign a
waiver and you have to get a physical
and you have to meet with them and
there's one other thing a doctor's note
I think you have yeah terrifying H give
you 20 grand if you can make it to the
end but no one ever has and this why I
brought it up because you're going to be
like I could easily make it through
there for sure you'd say that right oh
yeah they've had way tougher people than
us not make it through it like army
people like legit guys been through boot
camp they don't make it through it what
are they tear gassing you and [__] yes
that's correct Brian and they're bearing
you alive yeah so apparently own made it
bearing you
alive I guess the owner like says he
concocts each show for every individual
contestant so they they need backround
information on you CU they go after what
they know you're afraid of I just li
like do I love water give you're
claustrophobic I love water dud I love
water uh what else oh mud dude I'm like
a piging [__] dude love me some mud if
you freeze me I'm going to get rock card
to that right now dude you freeze me I'm
getting rock
hard this is weird no one in one hour
and 48 millions of people giving up I
guess they have like people are throwing
up and all like they and people have
tried to sue him but he he records
everything so people would say they you
know this guy did this to me and they
touched me like this he's like cool
check out the video they've never been
sued it must be insane yeah so the owner
of it says nothing weird goes on in the
manor despite a report from the guardian
which apparently came out but he says
you may be bound masked held underwater
slapped and stomped on and compelled to
eat your own vomit during the 8-hour
tour it's an 8 Hour F Well I mean hours
of fun but 20 G's it's not going to be
your haunted house up yeah but eight
hours I mean you know all right when
when he ask me my own throw like I'm
sorry when do you scare me though like
this is disgusting right like are you
making me intense I sign up for fair
Factor you going to sting me with murder
Hornets I mean there how about I just go
on Fair Factor Make 50 g if I'm doing
this [__] correct but I wonder what
they scare you with I really want to
know do you want to see this video real
Qui yeah I know we can't play how long
is it an hour so we'll skim through it
so they're not going to show it I'm sure
they're not going to show like the it's
basically like Isis videos looks like it
holy [__] no thanks 20 GS if you make it
through it you got dude I bet when you
get to the very end he's like I don't
have 20 G we better really ramp this
up Jesus Christ you know it's like we
better ramp this up Jesus no thanks I
wonder how scary it get my thing is it
scary is it just basically a shitty part
of like Navy's buds like a Navy SEAL
buds Camp it's that's what it looks like
but it says haunted house
I feel like it would be like us doing
this stun gun thing like it just like
you know it's not going to kill you but
it'll freak you out I feel like a little
more than that chin no but that kind of
like Direction no I feel like they meet
with you and then at you're about to get
to the end they like remember you're
molested when you're in Jerry's here
Jerry is here we flew him in from
Birmingham Alabama Birmingham Alabama
he's like yeah right and he's like
what's up Frank you're like oh my God
I'm out they do weird [__] like that
just dark [__] how dark can it get I
don't know I don't know like it just it
really caught my interest the number one
thing I'm not doing that ever and I
don't think I could make it through it
I'm not even going to flex on you guys
the one thing I want I want to go to New
Orleans and do their haunted tour it's
like New Orleans is such a deep yeah
I've had friends who done that it's
interesting don't want up me like I had
friend doing something unless you've
done it I don't care it's more it's more
of a like a you know it's like you never
been though I hate when people do know
you had a friend who did it it's it's
not scary though it's more uh like like
you see like you see Housewives and
people just like oh you know they it's
not what you think it is there's nothing
like that well hell no it is like that I
don't that I don't but there is some
Voodoo [__] in New Orleans there's some
weird [__] where you go you walk by a
store and you're like if I got is that
store like just a front to get people in
there and turn you into a [__] yeah you
know they're dungeons New Orleans has a
deep history of that stuff I love that
stuff especially when the Sun goes goes
down now around especially after
midnight there's a whole new world that
comes to life in nans I'm talking about
what go what's allowed there's this
vampire [__] going on oh yeah right yeah
yeah they speaky these people don't know
about and all of a sudden you walk in
and you're like what's this we am I in
the inside of a [__] Genie bar you
remember when we were touring like 8
years ago 9 years ago out there went to
the oldest bar in America yes I feel
like they lied to us cuz I feel like
that bar would be in Jamestown but
that's fine but when we went there I
remember that it was the black something
it was like Black Anvil I don't it was
like a little black almost cave you
couldn't see [__] yeah bring that up see
anything I thought I was talking to
Brian was just some old lady with the
same nose remember that leit blacksmith
shop bar y that's where we went laits
that is that is an old oldest structure
in the United States that's great it is
great 1722 173 so haunted i h my piss
for exactly 2 hours yeah I was so scared
in there I remember that it's so dark
even the lighting's from the 1700s you
can't there's candles look at it's dope
though I love New Orleans I love that
too I don't like the whole beet all that
[__] I like yeah I dude I get a
little uh what they call you know what
you know where you would love man Paris
you have that stuff like you go to Paris
and they have bars like that where you
just go in and you're like the marble
like in Rome too but are there French
people there Rome and I know but in
France are there French there there are
now hold on I'm out no but just just
hear me out no like you could go there
and no and you just got to go with a
French couple French people I got some
friends I like French oh look up I don't
like the French but you go in there and
it's just like like Rome's that way too
the marble has been worn out from years
it's like a it's a building of the
Romans belt you're there 700 years old
and you're like what am I doing I like
haunted stuff no it's not haunted okay
you don't think so I don't think so you
don't think that like the call but I
don't know all the people that died in
there yeah well if there's going to be
somewhere haunted would you not sleep in
the Coliseum at night
alone I would shoot it for content in
the catacombs I'd do some crazy content
the catacombs that that's haunted [__]
now we talking Daddy yeah but we could
just hey [__] that long travel we just
go to New Orleans
dude but I I feel like you New Orleans
comedy town I wish I went there more I
love it there I'm into all that haunted
stuff I like jazz I like Ben yeah I I
spent a lot of time in New Orleans I
shot a movie there
you know I I'm not not my favorite place
in the summer too hot winter time when
you go when you stick to those little
areas like you were talking about better
better True Detective was was down there
the first season True Detective oh that
was good Bo God that was good [__] dude
there's a new show on Netflix
called oh Usher Something the family us
the center the center NOP NOP NOP oh
Fall of the House of Usher have you
started watching it I only saw the
trailer but it looks good oh dude it's
so good it is you'll like it cuz I I
started watching CU I thought it was
going to be like a new scary thing yeah
not that scary there's some stuff in
there there's the girl from that move I
I went to theater the one with the
silver hair Samantha no the other the
silver hair no the other one the other
one Samantha oh red with the chin she's
killing it talking about the one with
the chin she's so pretty talking about
Quagmire no she's a pretty one dude
she's a good actor oh yeah the one with
the silver hair is fantastic she plays a
lesbian uh in this and
this is them they have to find out who
spoke to the feds and they get no no no
no no there's there's some weird thing
that's killing off all the family
members oh Jes and the dad that woman's
scary and the dad's the Le like
basically invented painkillers and he so
they have this huge family royalty and
all the kids are dying off and but the
way they're dying is crazy I won't ruin
it for you it's so good
wow love it it's very well done love it
yeah started watching I only watch
Halloween stuff on October dude we have
the pumpkin patch lined up uh KN of
jacks coming up
here you you're not a pumpkin patch guy
huh I don't
know
no sometimes I get I get bad flashbacks
in my life I get mad I just went
somewhere dark right now you did yeah
you got problems bud I
know I get mad about my career because
of certain things hey man sorry BR I
know I just see friends of mine on shows
and I get I'm like oh that so that
triggered you I thought it was a
pumpk some [__] triggers me where I get
what's the word angry is not the word is
is it is it rage is it a silent howl no
you're not howling inrage inrag yeah
that's what inrage and so when you saw
her she's crushed she's in Midnight M
she's fantas I love her as a person has
everyone in here seen midnight happy for
we get to Brian's issues was amazing
midnight mask no and it's Halloween you
got to watch it oh my God she's a great
person Samantha slen I'm so happy oh
it's good oh I did watch this oh it's
good she's such a good actress but you
got to understand I knew her forever and
she was stuck it out for so long for 20
years before she made it and that's
that's that's a badass and she's always
been a great person and a great actress
and she but seeing her how she's
crushing it that's what back no no no
it's not seeing her and how she's
crushing it I love her and I I know that
it's not a jealousy thing it's no it's
yeah it's um it's uh yeah I associate
certain things with certain things and
it makes me angry I get it that happened
that happened to you at skank that
happened to you at skank and there's no
getting BR back I that remember you got
mad we didn't well you came and watch
the game
with after that cuz I don't have that
energy and I had to get on stage so I
just like oh Brian going to do his thing
so I went my way you did yours and then
afterwards I saw I saw a certain woman
who I don't like and yes yeah and I was
like oh okay yeah that triggered you
yeah it triggered me that's okay though
o
Gina she's so hot yeah she's great oh
God yeah she's great I worked with her I
did a reading with her and I worked with
her on Entourage she's so pretty and oh
my God she's so pretty and she's also
she's in lingerie in this new show oh
God she is such a babe and remember her
in in Sin City was that it where she's
basically naked Jesus daddy God damn it
she's Beauty she is such a woman Gina
[__] such a woman yeah Gina uh what
her last so pretty I thought she was
English damn it no she's a just a Class
Act she's just classy gal classy classy
broad as they used to say back in the
Gina uh is this her or no yeah hell yeah
that's her Carla G Carla that's it
Sebastian beat it just Italian is
[__] beautiful and she's such a good
act she's in all my favorite shows God
except for San Andreas
[__] I remember her like that either had
a great career son-in-law was great
she's oh yeah she was in son-in-law oh
Patrick Rea I know Patrick I was in
acting school with know all these guys I
know Paulie the hell is it what is this
show this movie was son-in-law with
Paulie Shore oh that's right Patrick's
great it was a good oh Emily Dole hell
yeah
Thumper
yeah Adam Goldberg Jesus he hasn't
worked in a while it's tough [__] being
just an actor is a [__] well the
strike's over now though right no it's
not sir they still didn't figure out a
deal no and they're I think farther than
ever away from oh no you got people I
I've been running what am I going to do
well I ran into people the people that
are really hurting like I yesterday this
guy who worked who was a a boom operator
my
T 95 days without work they are they are
no they're living paycheck to paycheck
like if you're the rock or Vin Diesel
like yeah they'll figure it out those
guys have all the money it's the people
that it's all the set the supporting
staff they're Fu I was one of those guys
I remember when my agent called me at
the first strike he said it's going to
affect you a lot 66 1966 that's exactly
right and but I was a guy who did all
the little jobs so I I would take
whatever and I would make I was making
you know I'd make my nut I'd make
whatever it was I would I would you do
what it takes 200 Grand you know
whatever it was y but in La you know you
got and when that dried up I remember I
was like oh boy because there was no
money to be had and that's one of the
reasons I started doing standup CU I
went wait this is how this goes yeah
this is how this goes I'm relying on a
bunch of people I don't know lawyers to
work out deals as this business seems to
change and as actors aren't even
important anymore to to to other people
oh no no I'm not doing that no no no I
also saw how hard then you met a big old
brown mule that's right Bubba come on
now right big dick podcast don't say
that part don't say that part I'm sorry
you know not a bad dick not a bad dick
right a bad dick solid dick yeah I mean
it's not right but it's a Well there we
go there he is right there he is oh hey
yeah solid Cal he's out there Cal Ripken
of dicks did he have fun show did he
have fun though did he have fun yeah he
gets wet that's it he gets wet there he
is he's enthusiastic I'll tell you that
yeah he's enthusiastic he's up and ready
to go there he is is he the first one up
he'll give it it his all yeah there he
is he's not late has a gag reflex up not
late yeah he will he barfs yeah all
right dick barf is disg nope we're out
I'm so sorry son I'm so sorry oh now
that's too far sonaz I apologize s is
literally going she's covering her
face she's like what the [__] did I sign
up you you've never seen the show before
we're both old enough to know better and
we we can't not bring it back to male
genitalia dude you know what crazy I
don't know if it's one of your current
events showtime and now it's no more
boxing no more Sports coverage no more
MMA no more you
Bellator all that's gone and I used to
have I I I mean I talked to my agents
and manag like God my life was so much
easier when I was a Showtime getting a
salary I didn't have to hustle as much
you know I maybe I shouldn't have went
on my own boy am I glad I did yeah cuz
the everyone's gone Espinosa the whole
branch is gone right all my boys Brian
Daly the even even the all the smoke all
of them gone Luke Thomas
gone so now you're out in the street
it's like all right I guess I got to
find
yeah he's part of that but I think
Luke's going be okay cuz he's part of he
does a show on CB CBS Sports CBS Sports
still continue so I'm assuming they fold
morning combat into that those guys are
great so hopefully they do but the whole
division's done but even all the smoke
cuz it's basketball still all the smoke
is I I'm not going to say what they're
doing I don't know it's public knowledge
but yeah okay why did um why does Dana
and Conor McGregor why did they give
Espinosa a hard time cuz you like him
he's a good guy one of the most
brilliant people I know he Oscar De La
Hoya's lawyer in his so why did they why
why do they give him a hard time you
know they like enemies cuz they want to
run the show espinos is like hold up
we've been doing this for how long and
it was on their platform so they buted
heads over you know whatever creative
differences then Dan always shits on him
but there's hey hey it's two Rich guys
fighting okay
okay it's like watching Elon and Mark
Zuckerberg fight okay yeah I don't want
to watch that [__] but that's Dana's
great too but espo is [__] brilliant
he's not the guy you want to argue with
brilliant brilliant man I bet Savage
too yeah but it's sad right Jim what is
going on here oh yeah let's play a
little game uh this is like the it's
going to honestly it's kind of lame but
just guess I'll give you three options
here yeah so the plate on that's closest
to Brian is number one right so you guys
just take a bite of that it's just beef
jerky 6 don't worry
okay I it's not some weird like e thing
it's going to be either alligator
ostrich or kangaroo let's see if you
guys can guess what it is oh I know my
animals okay so the first one try
that I I can usually tell by looking at
it yeah no I
can this is good huh The Mask has too
much pepper that's the
thing kangaroo just spin it h no so I
don't have it in my mouth I taste the
next one oh so that would be I'm saying
number one is alligator what was what
alligator what ostrich
kangaroo Okay I like it tasty actually
I've never tasted Rue before so I don't
know yeah Rue is different all right so
we we tried it in Australia I think we
did we had alligator we had alligator
for sure yeah all right second one that
one's gy that's
alligator that [__] tastes like a
swamp
two's alligator that [__] is gay me
Daddy could be a mean kangaroo though
too that one's disgusting Ryan's really
thinking that one's [__] disgusting
I'm going to say two is alligator no you
said one's alligator you already yeah
yeah you did say alligator don't copy me
dude all right two's
alligator all right number
three two
is
Kangaroo tough meat kangaroo that's
kangaroo that's that's a hamstring of a
kangaroo Okay that's a hamstring of a
kangaroo three is
alligator interesting said allig for I
can't even keep track anymore I don't
even know here here here I am Brian can
do this thing three is uh kangaroo two
is alligator one is whatever that next
thing is ostrich sure okay renon you're
wrong about all those right you what it
it's the pepper I'm saying three three
is alligator it threw me for
now three is cuz you said no no I'm
making my choice three cuz it's the
toughest so three is alligator for sure
that's alligator tale okay and then so
three is alligator I would say what are
I what are my choices kangaroo ostrich
next that's that's it oh and then I
would say um I would say ostrich two is
ostrich one's and one is a rue dude you
guys got them all wrong this is insane
so number one number one is alligator
number two is Kangaroo number three is
ostrich tast three was
terrible so that's ostrich number one
was about alligator's by far the tasti
that's so crazy cuz alligator is not
that tasty usually what's it well give
me the ingredients of those oh [__] off
it's just beef Jersey
brhd Fresh pepp Sal pepper it would been
better if they weren't seasoned my eyes
are bad this is entertaining so the
ingredients alligator Beef Pork salt
spices brown sugar molasses papra onion
they and pork so [__] off I mean they
have to do they yeah yeah I've had
alligator ribs in Florida and they put
you know what they put in the you know
what this in the beef and the pork it's
pork lips and and beef tongue by the way
it tastes great I I like it sometimes
Calamar is pig anus I believe that it's
not yeah you want you want a plate a pig
anus or they use the four skins
of dude yeah you fry the foreskin dude I
don't know if this is fake news or not
Jim but did you see the guy
from Pizza gate got arrested for uh
child pornography no I remember the
owner I I met with this guy when I met
with him I went there and I said I feel
bad for you pizza's delicious I don't I
I will be amazed if this is the case
uh I don't see anything
no there it is that's July 20 no that's
that's the embassy journalist ABC
journalist how about we uh a scumbag oh
no he no so he was the guy investigating
spy gate who said it was all [__]
now he gets busted [__] that guy yeah
that's what's interest this just adds to
the theory he had sadistic child I've
been to Comic pizza and it is fantastic
that guy needs to put a bullet in his
own head [__] that agree
agree what else you got chin any more
weird Meats for Brian's mouth no but um
once again so Conor McGregor remember he
had that little incident in the bathroom
the girls was saying like he raped her
or sexually assaulted whatever and then
they're playing like getting drinks like
an hour later yeah they're hanging out
afterward we got her we got the Trevor
Bower accuser we got M all coming out
now very is it we all women right it's
all Bs cool anyway so that yeah so they
investigated no charges he's good to go
it seems a u the um I haven't heard much
about the Russell Brand stuff either
that seems to have gone rather quiet
yeah I didn't look too much into it but
uh after seeing all these different
cases I'm like come on dude I don't know
yeah I Russell Brand but you know what
like the Russell Brand stuff I don't
know what's going on there pizza gate
all this crap all this is overshadowed
rightfully so with the Israel the
Palestine like you realize like what is
important what's not when 60% of you
know Palestine is kids and they're
getting bombed and stuff like the
allegations we'll get to that Gaza Gaz
Gaza like we'll get to that but with the
everything going on like that should be
the focus yeah couldn't ain't it crazy
how they don't like Biden was wanted to
go out there like we're good well he's
out there now he's he's in Israel now
but what you know what they're trying to
avoid what is World War Three well
they're trying to avoid a two three and
four five front War I mean the remember
Hezbollah is in the north Hezbollah is
the is the militarized sort of proxy
wing of Iran in Lebanon they are very
well-armed with crazy rocketry Etc and
Israel does not feel like fighting them
but they may have to they've got got
bunker bombs that can penetrate a th000
feet into the ground I don't like any of
this yeah and and they but they they
know where all the [__] is but they
don't want to have that war so what
Biden is trying to say to to Iran with
those aircraft carriers he's snarling at
him going hey guys don't [__] around
here you know I don't need this you
don't need this you definitely don't
need it cuz if the red white and blue
come you may well the problem is if
Israel if if you make Israel fight
Hezbollah we might get drawn into this
because remember
1983 killed all those Marines it was the
worst single terrorist incident in
before 9/11 so you know Marines and
Americans have long memories about
anxiety stress me out I avoid the news
right now stay off the Twitter timeline
I I always I keep saying that what
happened what what the Israelis did is
separate from the Israeli Palestinian
conflict people want it to talk about
Palestinians and what get into you yeah
yeah you're right what do you got J okay
so this is just some footage dash cam
footage of oh Jesus what yeah so I'll
just show you this clip so everyone's
there's no lifethreatening injuries so
I'll just show you this clip I think the
17-year-old driver kind of veered off
into a lane if if you ever watched
Disturbia with Shila Buff this reminds
you of this yeah I remember that he's in
the blue car no just keep watching just
keep watching he's going really
fast you're a good man so listening to
an audio book or something this
guy
yeah it's like a movie Jesus Christ no
that's real he drifted oncoming traffic
yeah 17-year-old driver and everybody's
fine everyone well they're no one's
dying from it so who knows exactly what
that who who was that in the car was
that this is a guy that had the dash cam
the 17-year-old driver is the one that
drifted off into the other lane and then
caused a wreck either fell asleep or tax
in I I imagine something like texting
cuz
1or too young to let people drive I feel
that way 17 hell yeah rather them drive
at 21 I got a horal AC at 17
GH you're just dumb at 17 here's a ring
camera full of [__] am I
right this is just like the timing here
is pretty crazy so this is a ring camera
someone with a gun try to enter to try
to do a home invasion and I'll just play
the video for you real
quick so that seems like the husband
coming in first
and he
enters and looks like that's his wife
coming in
mhm got the left literally this guy
comes in with a gun tries to get him she
immediately slams the door and locks it
so and then he's on the ring but he's
hiding that's and he's trying to like
jack up the ring camera
too anyway it's like a close call she
climb the door right in holy
[__] this
guy he's has such a good attitude he got
his uh jaw basically destroyed by a
grizzly bear damn it like ripped his
[__] off ripped his jaw yeah uh he was a
he was hunting nah there's a p there's a
video of him talking when it happened I
know I mean I don't want to play the
video let me see pictur let me give us
the good [__] CH see the old lady almost
get robbed who got shot this [__] is
crazy I'm just afraid of us getting like
flagged well no we don't have to play it
on a man but for the entertainment let
me see jaw look at him right here first
that's his daughters all right they got
hit by beers too no so anyway he was
hunting deer they got a deer but then
they had to look for it you know after
you kill it cuz they kind of you know
run off somewhere and then as soon as he
found it there was a grizzly bear that
came at him he had bear spray but there
was another bigger grizzly bear that
actually attacked him after that damn
and his homies his buddies actually were
shooting so they scared the bear away
but by that time he already like ripped
off part of his jaw and they're using so
that's his jaw right there his
face and they're using part of his
leg to repair his jaw his tibula I think
damn that's cool yeah technology but
he's like he's like he's willing to go
back out there again he's like I'm going
to win round two and what's the round
two though if he ever fights a win this
thing no he's not oh wait Travis Kelsey
and T
Taylor and I'm IA before Travis Kelsey
started dating her I was like such a fan
I'm like all right I'm sick of this dude
I'm a fan of God I know um all right you
want to see him talk yeah I'd like to
see him talk without a jump dude he he
he do it for the gram he gets on there
and just starts talking while his face
is ripped off you got no idea
buddy no you got to see him talking no
you got to see him when he did it Tru
feel blessed to they took a video of him
I also want to say not this which one
you talking about where he they have
video of him after he got his face that
are you sure yeah he's talking I do not
think saw instam have you ever seen this
where the guy got his face oh my God
take a look at we seen the guy got
attacked in the head and his Skin's like
folded
down I don't think I've seen it bro okay
there's maybe it's not him but you got
to see this one you got to see watched
where the guy is talking he got his face
ripped off no his face but it's just
like it's hanging we've seen no not that
not that one I'm I'm telling you it's
like he's literally like type type in uh
grizly bear attack attack I don't want
to see
it uh
video no it's not that it's
it's I remember this one not that
one this guy no it's so unbelievable
you're like what the [__] this looks
crazy yeah let's not watch it so shitty
I'll find you know why we shouldn't
watch it cuz it's not on there is it it
is I'll find it for you I swear cuz it's
not on there is it I promise man this
what we deal I feel like it'd be on Tik
Tok or something what these [__]
Bears can do to your face oh Jesus have
you guys seen this video this is in
Colorado mhm so there's a I guess
there's like a train ride that goes
through the mountain area and then U
they saw this look like the a Bigfoot
sighting it's an elusive creature yeah
this in Colorado they said that was
Bigfoot squatting
down that's just a hunter let me youram
that's a hunter and like the camel Gear
with all the weird leaves on it I mean
he's definitely dressed up as like a
Sasquatch but I mean they're saying
obviously it's some dude doing a h big
button I don't care what anybody say hey
what the hell that hot girl in a
dissolving swimsuit is is she all right
she okay though no I want to make sure
she's okay I don't know it takes 8
minutes to dissolve oh jesz Jes I want
to make sure she's all right because
that's no joke this looks legit oh this
looks legit um all right okay I'm joking
hey girl an impossibly hot body put this
dissolving swimsuit on pretend you don't
know be
careful oh here we go this is crazy I
can't believe you did this I can't
believe Brian clicked on this [__] keep
going chin I didn't chin did damn it
chin don't
listen uh oh let's go to home J Leto
yeah let's boyfriend oh so so na has
this
one okay so you guys remember uh Natalie
Holloway oh yeah that whole mystery of
how she got killed sh the dude finally
came out and was like yeah not only did
I kill her but I kept trying to grope
her and she kept telling me no she kneed
me in the nuts I kicked her in the face
took a cinder block and damn yeah I'm
sure he so he just came out then then he
killed another woman in Peru he's in a
Peruvian jail now really oh yeah he's a
serial killer a disgusting damn
disgusting human
being that's terrible man so there's a
lot you know some bad ones here here's
another I'm taking this stuff with Jade
and Britney Spirits just sell books they
just throw everybody under the bus okay
but but Brit's coming out and saying at
19 her and Justin got pregnant and that
to sell books move on [__] he's moved
on he has kids in a family now the only
one bat Shake crazy she's America's
favorite knce knife dancer right now
true she is America's favorite knife
dancer and also they were together for 3
years they were 19 Justin's like
yeah okay what but it is part of her
life and I think it's very very
important there's Hamas and then there's
this and I think we need to she needs to
sell books that's
it check this out this video here so
this is a plane someone's in filming
from a plane looking at another plane
looks like the plan's actually paused in
the air slow on current events hey man
look watch d look pretty crazy yeah it's
cuz it's this his plane is moving faster
than that plane but doesn't it look
crazy though yes yeah it does look like
it's chilling huh yeah that is actually
cuz there's a bridge underneath
it
yeah you want more crazy stuff bro but
if you know how the plane is coming
closer to him so I mean it's not going
farther away so this is for Brennan CU
he loves Jared letto mean he bu jumped
into the and by the way he does a lot of
like height stuff right he look how many
tickets he sells oh my Lord so yeah this
is him bungee jumping into the crowd
yeah I'm sure that'll look like my crowd
in in Chicago this week this next
weekend but I mean he's like a
daredevil hard pass Bor to you this dude
is just so boring dude no that's so
insane I
wouldn't yeah that's scary I wouldn't
like that at all no cuz you trust the
Rope I would never trust that little
bungee cord yeah no good way I'm sure he
did it in rehearsal but oh yeah so high
up it's too crazy so high up yeah I'm
not big on Heights would you do that no
have you have you bungee jumped no I
would never Pros cons pros you get a
little bit of excitement adrenalin con
you die yeah it there's a bunge jump
there's a video of a guy bunge jumped
and he touched a crocodile is that true
you know that one where he hits the
water and you see a Croco like in the
water would you skydive I have yeah okay
I wouldn't do any of that but now I got
kids so I don't want to crocodile
alligator
yeah see if this is
real oh he got decapitated oh my Lord we
can't show any of this obviously is that
true it looks like
it it only has 16,000 views but it's
like a long 10 years ago 10 years
ago on we can't really show any it there
there that one that one Croc grabs bunge
jump let me see
this that's the same video yeah same one
oh sh that's not that's not can't be
real no that's not real the timing of
that that's it's it's [__] right
that's not 1.9 million views on this see
him from that high well if he touched
it that's not real yeah oh yeah it's
[__] never mind sorry it's [__]
anyway I think that's it man yeah
I'm sick your [__] what do you mean
I was just saying all the videos want to
make sure guy there's a video draw gets
ripped off guys I tell you what if you
if you don't like video and the you like
the real thing you come see me at uh
Chicago improv October 27 28th and then
Raleigh good nights I'll be there
November 9 10 and 11 let's go yuck yucks
Calgary November 16 17 and 18 Jesus
can't stop won't stop and then we got
December 78 and nine in helium Indiana I
don't know why I'm doing Thursdays but I
am you'll be all right I'm in Niagara
Falls New York November 3rd and 4th
Friday Saturday hey look at my hand
those almost sold out I know C sen
casino but basically Buffalo nagar Falls
New York uh Brett Forte will be with me
that's November 3rd and 4th then Chicago
December 8th and 9th we have a bunch
more dates be announced in January
coming up so stay tuned thick boy.com uh
fight compan with Joe Rogan Eddie Bravo
and myself will be live on
YouTube I said you oh you didn't but
it's okay um that will be live on Joe
Rogan's YouTube and then get uploaded to
Spotify that's UFC 294 fight capan JRE
all right we love you guys we're out